thousands of delegates from around the
world are in the German city of Bonn
they're racing to resolve outstanding
issues in implementing the Paris climate
Accord nearly 200 countries signed the
agreement back in 2015
committing to limit of the century's
global average temperature increase to
no more than two degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial levels we'll have more on
the issues in just a moment but first
here's a look at how countries compare
in terms of co2 emissions with 28
percent of global emissions China is the
biggest offender the United States at 16
percent comes in at number two Germany
with just over 2 percent comes in 6th
place but it's a very different story
when you look at per capita emissions
here Qatar comes out way on top the
average person there emits over 30 tons
of co2 each year that's the ice as much
as the average person in the US and many
times the global average of less than 5
tons per head now carbon trading the
buying and selling credits to emit co2
is a big topic at those climate talks I
mentioned earlier today I spoke to
Stefan Rahmstorf
a climatologist at the Potsdam Institute
for climate and research I asked him why
he thinks that carbon trading would be
an effective measure to curb emissions
it's basically essential part of getting
out of the co2 emissions because as I
said we're fighting against the market
prices
if emitting is simply free indeed now
you've talked about the role of new
technologies could you tell us a little
bit more about what industry's role
should be in terms of achieving the
climate goals well first of all some of
the fossil Industries need to stop
lobbying against climate protection and
climate legislation it's been recently
revealed that the five biggest oil
companies alone spent 200 million
dollars per year lobbying and delaying
climate against like climate legislation
and I think industry needs to change
their business model to be compatible
with a Paris agreement or
then trying to cling to the old one and
trying to undermine the implementation
of the Paris agreement and what advice
would you have for governments in terms
of trying to combat this kind of
lobbying that you mentioned from
corporations to try and undermine the
reaching of these goals well the
government's shouldn't basically listen
too much to special interest lobbying
but have the interest of humanity and
their own citizens on their mind first
and foremost but is there any way to
ensure that that happens is there any
mechanism to ensure that governments put
humanity's interests first and not
corporate interests well I think
basically the people have to put
pressure on the government as it's
happened happening now for example with
the worldwide Friday's for future
movement where the students are
demonstrating in the streets and we have
seen already in Germany that that has
really woken up the politicians who
really haven't they've lost the last ten
years in terms of emissions reductions
and now our Chancellor she's last week
she visited our Institute for example
she's putting climate protection back
near the top of the agenda and that's
where it belongs so that sounds like a
rather hopeful development you're often
quoted as saying that the future of
civilization is at stake whenever you've
been quoted in the media do you feel
heard well not enough obviously because
we have very little time to lose now we
are currently we can still emit
worldwide around about 800 billion tons
of carbon dioxide and that is about 20
years worth of co2 emissions and then
we've emitted so much that we can't stay
well below 2 degrees as is stipulated in
the Paris agreement anymore so it's a
race against the clock now because
politicians haven't listened for the
last decades to the science after all
first official report warning for from
global warming dates from 1965 a message
of urgency from mr. Stefan Rahmstorf
he's a climatologist at the Potsdam
Institute for climate and research thank
you very much thank you